From calorie count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Krispy Kreme in the UK and the US.
This is Food Wars.
In the UK, we can get doughnuts
in four portion sizes.
As a single doughnut,
as a three,
a dozen,
or you'll be the life of the
party with a double dozen.
In the US, you can get
your doughnuts in single,
two, if you get it with a coffee combo,
three-pack,
dozen – look at these beauties –
or two dozen.
Now technically, the double dozen
isn't the biggest thing on the UK menu.
Krispy Kreme in the UK
will cater for events
like your weddings or your parties.
And they can do something
called a doughnut wall,
which contains 216 doughnuts
hanging on pegs on a wall.
That's 18 dozen.
Krispy Kreme will also make you something
called the doughnut tower.
It looks almost like a wedding cake
and is made of around 216 doughnuts.
You've got to give them a heads up though,
because I went to the Krispy Kreme today
and asked for one and they said no.
Also in the US at Krispy Kreme
you can get mini doughnuts in four or 20.
I have to know.
Uh oh, I'm in trouble.
I don't know if I'm going to make it
through this shoot, Conner.
These are so good.
This right here is a standard
USA Krispy Kreme classic glazed doughnut.
I want to bite into you so bad.
But before that, let's weigh it.
Now we're going to weigh a
glazed doughnut in the UK
to see what it comes to.
Oh, they're so light.
In the UK, our hot coffee
sizes are regular and large.
US Krispy Kreme,
you can get your coffee in three sizes:
small, medium, and large.
And if you're really thirsty,
you can get yourself a Brew Box.
Nice.
A large hot coffee in the UK
is supposed to be 16 ounces.
So we're going to measure that
to find out if that's true.
And to make sure that this reading
is absolutely accurate,
got a big boy.
OK.
Krispy Kreme in the US,
you can get your iced
coffees in two sizes,
medium and large.
Iced coffees in the UK
also come in two sizes,
regular and large.
They use the same cups as the hot coffees.
They've ditched the plastic ones
apparently to cut down on plastic waste.
And now we're going to measure
our iced coffee, black.
Oh, definitely more coffee.
Now besides doughnut walls,
the biggest thing on the UK menu is this,
the Sharer Bundle.
It's four dozen doughnuts,
and it comes to 41 pounds and 95 pence.
This here is the largest single menu item
you can get at a US Krispy Kreme.
It is the Meet and Greet.
Two dozen assorted doughnuts
and a Brew Box, all for $42.95.
Let's look at nutrition.
This is a classic ring glazed
doughnut from Krispy Kreme,
and it contains 200
calories, 8.3 grams of fat,
12.6 grams of sugar, and
96 milligrams of sodium.
That same doughnut in
the US is 190 calories,
11 grams of fat, 10 grams of sugar,
and 85 milligrams of sodium.
Ours is less with everything except fat.
Few people can stop
after just one doughnut.
So if you just had to have three of these,
the calories go up.
Now you're looking at 600 calories,
which is 30% of your daily allowance.
And in the US, these three doughnuts
are slightly less in calories.
It's 570 over here.
But look at how much sugar
these three doughnuts had.
It's almost three-fourths
what you should be having in one day.
Speaking honestly though, if I have these
it's not like I'm going
to have a salad for lunch.
Getting a dozen doughnuts
for you and your friends
or just yourself,
that would put you at 2,400 calories.
And in the US, our dozen
comes to 2,280 calories.
I would hope you wouldn't eat
all 12 of these by yourself.
But if you do, I guess
that's all the calories
you're going to need for the day.
I could eat 12 of these, easy.
Another popular doughnut at Krispy Kreme
is the chocolate glazed.
Just ignore the sprinkles on ours
because we didn't have any plain ones.
Now, this one is 237 calories
and also beats the classic glazed
in pretty much every other metric,
probably because of
the chocolate frosting.
Our US chocolate glazed is 240 calories.
So it looks like the chocolate glaze
helped put us over the top.
What?
If you want even more
calories in your doughnuts,
how about the UK's
chocolate iced with custard?
Now this one is 289 calories.
And ours is 300 calories.
300, just this one doughnut?
I'm definitely going to regret it.
That tastes so good.
In the UK, the most calorific
doughnut is this one,
the Lotus Biscoff doughnut.
It's 396 calories.
The most calorific
doughnut you can get at a Krispy Kreme,
at least in America, is something called
the chocolate chip cookie dough doughnut,
made with Chips Ahoy! cookies.
And it is 400 calories.
They weren't available where we went.
And the second most calorific
doughnut you can get
at a Krispy Kreme is the Oreo
Cookies and Kreme doughnut.
That's 390 calories.
Also couldn't get it.
The third most calorific doughnut
you can get at a Krispy
Kreme in the United States
is the double dark chocolate doughnut.
370 calories.
No.
And the fourth most calorific
doughnut you can get
at a US Krispy Kreme is
the cake batter doughnut.
360 calories.
We got it.
This is a nice-looking,
this is like white.
I mean, this is sprinkles, it's colorful.
Oh man, I'm fading fast.
I shouldn't, I'm going to
drink all those coffees.
What about the drinks?
Well, this is a large mocha with 2% milk.
And in the UK it contains 247 calories,
16.3 grams of fat, 12 grams of sugar,
and 80 milligrams of sodium.
In the US, our large
mocha is 480 calories,
1 gram of sugar, and 260
milligrams of sodium.
Come here, you salty mocha dog.
Whoa, this is good.
I'm surprised, I thought
I wasn't going to like it.
I normally don't get chocolatey drinks.
If you get this as an iced coffee,
it contains 280 calories,
12 grams of sugar,
and 14 milligrams of sodium.
Do you want to get it iced?
Now the calories are
420, 2 grams of sugar,
and 190 milligrams of sodium.
Since the UK and US sizes are different,
we've calculated it per fluid ounce.
And we found some pretty
shocking differences.
From the UK to the US, there's
a 55.5% calorie increase,
a 93.3% sugar decrease,
and a 160% sodium increase.
I've eaten way too many doughnuts
on this thing, dude.
I'm losing, losing my ---ing mind.
And in the US, our doughnut
is made up of:
I'm getting better at this.
And it contains less than
2% of each of the following:
Ah yes, our old friend BHT,
aka butylated hydroxytoluene?
It is banned in the European Union.
The International Agency for
Research on Cancer suggests,
might I say strongly suggests,
there is sufficient evidence
that BHT causes tumor
growth in lab animals.
Also, according to WebMD,
BHT is also used to treat genital herpes.
All right:
Yolks, yolks, egg yolks.
All right, scratch that.
I'm having a tough time with this one.
That last guy, diammonium
phosphate, aka DAP
Not the sequel to WAP.
It is also used as a fertilizer
and as a fire retardant.
So when we have the next
wildfire outbreaks in the state,
because it definitely will happen,
we're going to start
dropping Krispy Kremes
on those wildfires.
Problem solved.
In the UK,
a glazed doughnut is
made of the following:
Oh, they're not done.
No.
Nope, there's more.
That was the doughnut.
Now we're going to talk
about what's in the glaze.
Sugar, water ...
That's a lot of
ingredients for a doughnut.
One thing worth pointing out
is the differences in the sprinkles
between the UK and the US.
Three of the colorings used in the US
are actually subject to
restrictions in the European Union.
And if they're included in
foods, they must bear a warning
that they may cause
hyperactivity in children.
Not here though, baby. Not here.
Blue 1 isn't actually on this list,
but it's also very hard
to come by in the UK.
It was famously removed from Smarties
in the UK several years ago.
And it took them three years
to find a natural alternative
to the blue color, which
ended up being spirulina.
Here is everything you
can only find on the menu
at a UK Krispy Kreme.
And these are all the things
you can get at a US Krispy Kreme.
Let's start with some doughnuts.
The first one we'll look at is this one,
the Lotus Biscoff.
Now, Lotus Biscoffs are
those little biscuits
which you usually get on
the side of a cup of coffee.
It's like a caramel-flavored
crunchy cookie,
and we're kind of obsessed
with them in the UK.
This one comes with some
crumbled-up Biscoff on the top.
And then I think the icing
also has Biscoff in it.
And there's also some Biscoff
injected inside as well.
Next up, we have this one,
which is a chocolate dream cake.
Caramel iced ring doughnut.
Nutty filled berry ring doughnut.
The purple Love Hearts doughnut.
Now this one's been
produced in collaboration
with Love Hearts, the candy,
as you can see by the
very cute phrase on top.
This is a varied thing.
We just got one that says OMG.
Next up, we have the Caramel
Sensation, Nutty Chocolatta.
Now it's actually a heart-shaped doughnut
with some chocolate icing on top.
And importantly, it's full of Nutella.
That's a little bit underwhelming.
I wanted more Nutella to come out there.
Pretty good.
And these are all the exclusive items
you can get at a US Krispy Kreme.
OK, so the US Krispy Kreme
has so many exclusive USA-only doughnuts.
But they're not available
at every Krispy Kreme.
So the one we specifically went to
had about a dozen of those doughnuts.
An original filled chocolate cream.
So you can see in the
little white spot there
that that is where they
put the cream in there.
Pretty sure that's an apple fritter.
That's the birthday cake.
And what we saw before, chocolate
icing filled with custard.
Yeah, that's definitely a custard one.
Can you see the yellow in there?
I'm going to assume this is
maybe the glazed sour cream cake?
Sugared ring and cinnamon sugared ring.
See this eclair right here?
New York City cheesecake.
Glazed raspberry-filled.
Oh, God.
That's not that much stuff in here.
So good.
I'm going to be so sick, and I don't care.
Also at the US Krispy Kreme,
you can get these doughnut holes.
They put them in these cups
that might be reusable.
The UK does not have these,
as before mentioned, minis.
It's usually 20, but the
crew got to them too fast.
I couldn't stop them.
Couldn't stop them.
Now on top of the doughnuts themselves,
the UK also has exclusive ways
of presenting the doughnuts.
For example, here we have a birthday box.
And you can also get a doughnut
with a customized message printed on it.
Unfortunately, we didn't
give them enough warning.
So maybe if the editor
can just add one here,
that would be great.
The Krispy Kreme in the US
has a lot of varieties
of hot and cold drinks.
You can get your lattes
in a version of vanilla,
caramel, or white chocolate.
And then the iced drinks.
Same rules as before.
Everything has a vanilla, white chocolate,
and caramel version.
This right here is the Malibu Dream.
It is a strawberry,
banana, and vanilla shake.
It tastes OK.
And we actually have a
few more things I forgot.
Oh, I almost forgot.
Get bottled drinks to go.
Krispy Kreme in the UK
also offers a range of exclusive shakes.
We have four of them here.
We have the Oreo shake, a
strawberry and cream shake,
the Lotus Biscoff shake,
and then this one is a
chocolate cream shake.
Back at it again with the Biscoff.
Like, what's the deal with that?
Why is everyone so obsessed with Biscoff?
I don't get it.
I'm just going to say I don't
like Biscoff, and I'm mad
that they've put it in so
many things on their menu.
I'm going to try the Oreo one,
because even though it's sat
under studio lights for several hours,
it still looks and smells pretty good.
Woo, that is very sweet, but pretty good.
We can also get some exclusive
iced drink options in the UK,
including a pink lemonade,
an original lemonade, a frozen
mango, and a coffee chiller.
Although unfortunately,
the ice machine was broken
when we went, so we
couldn't get them today.
And finally, apparently you guys can't get
flat whites in the US,
which is surprising,
because we drink those
all the time in the UK.
It's kind of just like a latte,
but with slightly less foam.
Hey, thanks for watching.
We have a new project coming
that we're really excited about.
And we're going to show you a
few seconds of it right now.
This is a Big Mac.
And this is everything
that's in a Big Mac.
Welcome to Fast Food Chemistry.
I feel like I'm watching
someone making an explosive.
This is potassium aluminium sulfate.
Soy lecithin, calcium
chloride, potassium sorbate,
polyoxyethylene sorbitan monooleate.
So there you have it.
Can you tell which one is ours?
But that looks, it
actually looks pretty good.
I'm very surprised by that.
That's right, we used every chemical
McDonald's uses to make a Big Mac.
But you'll have to tune in next Sunday
to see how it turned out.
Be sure to subscribe to Food
Insider so you don't miss it.
Soy lecithin.
Did you hear that?
Yeah, my stomach's churning,
all these doughnuts.
This was a mistake and the
best mistake I've ever made.
I don't care how I feel,
these doughnuts are so good.